the new school year is now in full swing
hundreds of thousands of kids going back
to class today
good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm bryan loftis and
i'm denise valdez it was a
busy day for the clark county school
district as they balance
first day celebrations with health and
safety kate houston is live in the
newsroom after sitting in on a talk
between school district leaders and
students
kate yes today nearly 4 000 students
attended class at
shadow ridge high school near the
northwest valley more than a dozen of
those students were able to sit down
to discuss their hopes for this year and
the future of education in clark county
class is back in session for clark
county school district students
it was just like a really good
atmosphere and all the kids are ready to
be back alexis abney is one of a handful
of students that sat down with
superintendent dr jesus jarrah state
superintendent joan ebert
and trustee katie williams to discuss
the upcoming year
what do we need to do to make sure that
this year
we give you the best year ever some hot
topics included bringing back
extracurricular activities
and modifying the curriculum to be more
project based
i think that would be great i know so
many students struggle with like quizzes
and really it is learning for a quiz and
then after that you forget it
overall many students wanted assurance
that schools would remain
open staying together like in school as
long as we possibly can
is probably going to be the most
beneficial superintendent jara echoed
those statements and was happy to see
students across the district taking
safety measures seriously
from kindergarten preschool to now you
see our high school students they're
wearing their masks they're
really taking care of their health and
really really really excited
of where we are today moving forward
superintendent jarrah stressed the
importance of following safety
guidelines to keep students like abny
in the classroom i love how it is right
now i think this is a really good start
and if we could at least keep it where
we're in school
we're having sports we're having
activities and just getting the school
spirit back
getting kids to want to be here and feel
included
superintendent jara says there were no
major challenges despite
restrictions from the pandemic the
school district is asking parents to
check in with their kids
every day before school and monitor any
symptoms school district staff are also
required to complete those daily
check-ins
back to you now kate if a student does
develop symptoms what is the protocol
for both the parents
and the school well parents need to
contact their school nurse who will
refer them
to one of six testing sites at local
schools now quarantine is being handled
on a case-by-case basis
with assistance from the health district
and parents will get a personal call if
their child was exposed
and if a student is vaccinated that can
actually help expedite that quarantine
process
back to you all right good info there
kate thank you for that